et on est de retour avec vous François
Bayrou bonsoir bonsoir merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous vous êtes maire de Pau
président du modèle et au commissaire au
Plan en 2005 il y a 18 ans au moment de
la privatisation vous étiez député UDF
vous y alors partie de la majorité
emmené par Dominique de Villepin et
pourtant UDF et rebelle EDF et rebelle
et pourtant à la télévision vous
affirmiez ceci je dis que le
gouvernement n'a pas le droit de le
faire que la loi interdit de privatiser
une entreprise dans laquelle l'État est
majoritaire sans qu'il y ait débat au
Parlement et vote d'une loi elle était
illégale cette privatisation
oui quand l'État a un patrimoine possède
un bien ce bien ne peut pas être
privatisé sans que le Parlement le
décide c'est le Parlement qui est le
défenseur
du patrimoine de la nation
et là on a décidé que
pour ces sociétés là on a des pouvoirs
les privatiser pour 30 ans 30 ans c'est
une éternité si vous reportez à 2005 et
si vous songez ce que vous étiez vous
étiez en culotte courte ou en 2005 et si
vous lisez
la saisine du Conseil d'État que j'ai
fait à titre personnel je suis allé
acheter une action de chacune des trois
sociétés d'autoroute c'est les seules
actions que j'ai jamais eu de ma vie
actionnaire pour pouvoir
aller devant le Conseil d'État et le
Conseil d'État finalement vous a donné
tort puisqu'il a rejeté votre requête en
expliquant grosso modo que c'était pas
l'état directement qui possédait les
sociétés autoroutes
un établissement public qui possédait
donc il n'y avait pas à passer par le
Parlement pour
imaginé gagner
je faisais ça pour qu'il soit faite
confiance affirmée
pour qu'il soit affirmé
que il y avait au moins un parlementaire
dans le pays qui n'acceptait pas cette
procédure vous aviez pris la parole
beaucoup dans les médias et Dominique de
Villepin le Premier ministre de l'époque
vous avez répondu ceci le standard de
Matignon fonctionne donc je rappelle à
François Bayrou le numéro du standard de
Matignon 01 42 75 80 00 il vaut mieux au
sein de famille proche que nous réglions
les problèmes que nous pouvons avoir
entre nous ça crée ambiance non à
l'époque non mais vous voyez bien c'est
l'idée
de faire ça entre nous
ce que Dominique de Villepin affirmait à
l'époque
c'est-à-dire l'idée qu'on peut choisir
une procédure qui ne respecte pas les
principes du droit et qu'on va
s'arranger entre nous faire des petits
arrangements entre amis et je n'ai
jamais accepté ça vous diriez que les
sociétés les gens du BTP qui ont obtenu
ces concessions arnaquer l'état donc je
pense que l'État s'est laissé
volontairement arnaquer c'est à dire il
y avait bien quelque part des gens à
cette époque qui savaient
que c'était dingue
et que c'était dingue pour une raison
très simple c'est que les sociétés
d'autoroute étaient pour ainsi dire
complètement
payé c'était fini c'était
l'investissement
remboursé que ça allait être rentable et
rentable pendant des années
et ça n'est pas possible de considérer
que personne dans l'état n'est compris
que c'était une très mauvaise affaire
pour l'État et une bonne affaire pour
les sociétés qui reprenaient ça a été
fait consciemment c'est-à-dire que
Dominique de Villepin vous pensez que ce
soit juste une erreur c'est je déteste
être les personnes en cause sans avoir
de preuve et puis que je pense que
l'État a plusieurs reprises
a décidé que au fond c'était
ces sociétés privées autoroutières ces
sociétés qui étaient de bons partenaires
pour l'État et que
pas seulement qu'il fallait pas se
fâcher que c'était bien d'avoir des
puissances comme celle-là alors les
accords de privatisation 2005 étaient
tellement déséquilibré en la défaveur de
l'État et en la faveur de ces sociétés
autoroutières que on l'a tenté de
renégocier ces accords en 2015 à
l'époque les discussions étaient menées
par un jeune ministre de l'économie qui
s'appelait Emmanuel Macron et écoutez ce
qu'il promettait à l'époque il y a trois
objectifs à cette discussion le gel des
tarifs en 2015
deuxièmement relancer l'investissement
c'est ce qu'attendent nos concitoyens
relancer l'investissement être plus
transparent on a mal géré ces contrats
ces dernières années on va être plus
transparent alors le plus transparent et
le jour même vous observez que d'une
certaine manière dans cette déclaration
il donne raison au combat que j'avais
mené et il promet aussi donc plus de
transparence le jour de cette interview
il signe ce fameux protocole de 2015
qu'il va refuser de publier malgré les
avis plusieurs avis de la justice
pourquoi voir voulu cacher les détails
de cet accord soit je sais pas je ne
suis pas au courant je me suis toujours
battu pour la pour la transparence et
pour la publicité la justice a
d'ailleurs donné raison et il allait
jusqu'en cassation pour ne pas publier
ce protocole est-ce que vous qui
connaissez bien vous lui avez dit
pendant ces quatre longues années
pendant lesquelles doivent vous dire
qu'on en a jamais parlé parce que ça n'a
jamais été un dossier intéressant
parce que là on parle d'Emmanuel Macron
ministre avant d'être candidat à la
présidentielle et je ne le connais pas
je lui ai jamais parlé à cette époque ça
voulait soit quelque part que vous
alliez d'aujourd'hui Alexis colère
Emmanuel Macron Elizabeth borne il n'est
pas réussi en 2015 pourtant ils
connaissent bien les dossiers
économiques il n'est pas réussi à tenir
tête à ces sociétés autoroutières qui
gagnaient déjà beaucoup d'argent
je vous dis c'est
l'ensemble de l'État au sommet dans ces
domaines de l'économie et de
l'équipement et vous voyez qu'en disant
ça j'évoque des administrations
ont avec ces sociétés puissantes
des relations qui sont des relations de
de confiance réciproque de c'est un
univers dans lequel on se connaît les
orques étaient dans une situation avant
d'être ils ont été dans le public avant
d'être dans le privé pour parler faut
parler simplement si j'essaie de
décrypter le ministre de l'économie et
le son directeur de cabinet de l'époque
sont peut-être fait avoir par la
puissance de la techno structure de
Bercy c'est ça que vous dites je dirais
pas ça sous cette forme moi je pense
qu'il y avait confiance c'est ce sont
des partenaires je pense simplement que
depuis le début dans cette affaire tout
le monde considéré que que c'était que
c'était une bonne démarche on a révélé
cette semaine avec nos donc offrir de
Marianne qu'une plainte avait été
déposée la semaine dernière par
l'association anticorruption anticorps
pour le délit d'octroi d'avantage
injustifié en gros le délite favoritisme
est-ce que c'est une bonne chose que la
justice enquête sur les coulisses de ce
protocole d'accord de 2015
c'est l'équilibre des pouvoirs et la
justice c'est une autorité qui est
exercée pour que la démocratie soit
équilibrée et donc
c'est normal et souhaitable alors on a
annoncé que vous étiez notre invité dans
les fauteuils rouges et on a reçu un
message d'un automobiliste qui voulait
vous poser cette question
bonjour monsieur Béraud pendant le débat
sur les concessions des taureau de vous
êtes montré un esprit libre est-ce que
vous le resteriez aujourd'hui et vous
demanderiez à Bercy à l'Élysée de mettre
la pression sur les sociétés d'autoroute
pour offrir pH gratuit pendant tous les
Théo français ou au minimum par des sens
par bon sens un aller-retour gratuit
pour leurs vacances voilà vous l'avez
reconnu hein soumis François Ruffin
est-ce que François Ruffin parfois ne
tombe pas du côté de la démagogie
systématique c'est ça c'est une question
que je pose amicalement vous qui êtes
pour le dépassement du du clivage
gauche-droite est-ce que vous pourriez
travailler avec l'adulpe et soutenir la
proposition de loi pour le droit aux
vacances et qui demande notamment que le
pH puissent être gratuit au moins pour
un aller-retour chaque été pour les vous
voyez les Français je pense que
c'est fait pour gagner des voix c'est
pas fait pour changer l'équilibre de la
société je vous ai dit tout à l'heure il
y a des parts de démagogie dans dans ces
attitudes de démagogie ou de je sais pas
comment on peut dire de faciliter de
c'est une mauvaise proposition c'est un
peu trop
facile elle est elle ne se réalisera pas
et pour gérer l'urgence aujourd'hui on
fait quoi le Conseil d'État a dit vous
pouvez s'il y a des profits excessifs
vous pouvez considérer qu'on peut créer
une fiscalité à condition qu'elle soit
pas contre un seul contribuable
c'est-à-dire ces sociétés là il faut
qu'elle soit plus générale auprès des
sociétés concessionnaires cette nouvelle
taxe elle pourrait d'après le
gouvernement rapporter deux à trois
milliards d'euros c'est rien au regard
des supers
mais si on compare par exemple on a
regardé le dernier rapport de l'Autorité
de régulation des transports qui étudie
l'impact de la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés de 33% à 25% c'était une
promesse de campagne d'Emmanuel Macron
en 2017 on voit que cette baisse d'impôt
a entraîné un gain de plus de 15,4
milliards d'euros pour les sociétés
concessionnaires des des autoroutes avec
15,4 milliards de ristourne fiscale on
peut baisser le prix des péages
le prix des péages est fixé dans
l'accord du premier jour c'est le jour
où cette décision a été prise que toutes
les conséquences étaient prévues et
devait s'enchaîner c'est ça qu'on a vu
et depuis les conséquences
c'était déjà un peu jaspin si vous étiez
Premier ministre aujourd'hui est-ce que
vous géreriez mieux ou différemment ce
dossier autoroute qu'Elizabeth borne
j'ai étudierai ce qu'on va faire à la
fin des concessions l'idée que les
revenus des autoroutes serviront à
équiper le pays devrait servir à équiper
le pays était une idée juste peut-être
il faudra y revenir donc vous vous
réclameriez une nationalisation d'ici
2030 réclame rien je dis que cette idée
d'avoir une gestion publique des
autoroutes quand les concessions seront
arrivées à leur terme ça c'est possible
ça c'est envisageable il y a là quelque
chose qui n'est pas démagogique qui est
possible
juridiquement et politiquement est-ce
que vous souhaitez devenir Premier
ministre si on cherche un remplaçant à
Elisabeth je suis hors de ce jeu je suis
pas disponible pour ça pour des raisons
que vous savez pourquoi vous en auriez
envie
mais dans la vie il arrive que vous ayez
envie de quelque chose et que vous
sachiez que ça n'est pas possible nous
allons avoir un procès que je considère
comme totalement infondé mais vous êtes
envoyé devant le tribunal à l'automne en
octobre pour des soupçons d'emplois
fictif au Parlement mais des soupçons
infondées c'est-à-dire c'est pas vrai
vous êtes tombé dans le tribunal donc
les les juges estiment que vous avez
commis des détournements de fonds
publics il y a eu des accusations
portant sur la totalité des
parlementaires européens c'était pas
parlementaire européen je suis président
du MoDem et la totalité des
parlementaires et tous les uns après les
autres ont été blanchis
il reste des soupçons datantis à 15 ou
17 ans et nous ferons la preuve que ce
n'est pas vrai mais ce qui explique que
bien entendu je n'aurais pas la
stupidité de postuler à des fonctions
alors que nous avons cet épisode
judiciaire là parce que ça va il y a des
députés qui ne sont plus poursuivi mais
d'après l'ordonnance de renvoi des
justes et voilées par nos collègues de
l'AFP c'est bien vous François Bayrou
apparaît comme le décideur et le
responsable de la mise en place de du
fonctionnement d'un système frauduleux
dans leur conclusion les juges
expliquent François Bayrou s'est rendu
complice par instigation de fait
d'étonnement public commis par des
députés européens donc c'est vous le
l'auteur principal
dans les yeux
j'aurais pu regarder aussi les juges
mais
vous regardez dans les yeux je dis ceci
est non seulement infondé mais
totalement et absurdement faux
on peut être non détox et dire des
choses de cet ordre totalement et
absurdement faux donc et donc non
laissez-moi finir et donc nous ferons la
preuve je ferai la preuve parce que
j'irai devant cette devant ce tribunal
et je ferai la preuve que tout ceci ce
sont des accusations
malveillantes et mensongères et je crois
j'espère mais je crois que la justice
est capable de
d'établir ce genre de fait donc après le
procès vous serez de nouveau candidat au
poste de Premier ministre voire de
président de la République inch'Allah
ça veut dire oui alors si vous êtes si
vous êtes si vous êtes est-ce que vous
avez l'impression que toutes les
déclarations que je vous ai faites
depuis le début est-ce que vous avez
l'impression que ça signifie que j'ai
l'intention de m'éloigner de la
politique non on a plutôt l'impression
inverse peut-être cette impression là
est juste la différence de ce que vous
disiez avant
et bien merci beaucoup François Bayrou
d'avoir accepté cette invitation